nous allons revenir en images sur les
derniers événements de la nuit et de la
matinée tels que nous continuons de les
vivre grâce à la télévision roumaine qui
nous envoie ses reportages de façon
ininterrompue
jean-marc il use comme un monstre vaincu
les restes calcinés de ce véhicule de la
rouerie date est abandonnée dans un
quartier périphérique de bucarest avant
un symbole non de la fin des combats
mais du renversement progressif de la
situation en faveur des insurgés et de
l'armée à bucarest même la situation
semble se normaliser peu à peu même si
de brefs mais violents affrontements se
sont déroulés une partie de la nuit
autour de la télévision tête politique
et stratégique de l'insurrection
à l'intérieur on a retapé le studio
cousue quelques drapeaux mais paradoxe
c'est dans une langue de bois très
proche du langage des proclamations de
l'ancien régime que le nouveau pouvoir
dénonce les forces anti populaires et
appelle la population à évacuer les
quartiers où les chars de l'armée ne
peuvent être efficaces tant que les
civils sont encore là le calme est à peu
près revenu en fin de matinée et les
combats se concentrent actuellement au
sud-est de la capitale autour du
ministère de la défense et au nord de la
ville où une poignée de desesperado de
la securitate et s'accroche toujours au
bâtiment de la gare mais voilà quarante
deux années de prière enfin exaucé pour
cette première mise noël noël de deuil
mais noël libre la roumanie au seuil de
sa victoire à louer le seigneur tout en
pleurant ses morts hier les tueurs de
ceausescu ont même tiré sur les fidèles
à l'entrée de la messe
je vous propose de retourner en direct à
bucca